bolivia está en modo electoral desde
este domingo 6 de septiembre con el
inicio formal de las campañas rumbo a
las elecciones del 18 de octubre se
trata de una campaña atípica porque
bolivia todavía está siendo fuertemente
golpeada por el coronavirus en este
contexto el tribunal supremo electoral
ha pedido a los partidos que se
enmarquen dentro de las restricciones
establecidas por la crisis sanitaria
pese a ello algunas fórmulas han
realizado concentraciones numerosas
sobre todo en la ciudad de santa cruz
por ejemplo el partido juntos de la
presidenta jeanine áñez ha pedido el
voto con una gran caravana en la capital
oriental por su parte el movimiento al
socialismo el partido del ex presidente
evo morales cuyo candidato es luís arse
ha lanzado su campaña a través de medios
digitales mientras que el candidato de
comunidad ciudadana carlos meza ha
lanzado varios mensajes a través de las
redes sociales en total ocho partidos
pugnan por la silla presidencial para
estas elecciones por las que bolivia
busca salir de la crisis profunda en la
que se encuentra desde noviembre del año
pasado
tras la abrupta salida de evo morales-
del poder